ja und Deutschland Deutschland will
helfen und zwar schnell unter anderem
hier mit mit Iris t wir sehen ein
hochmodernes Luftverteidigungssystem es
kann eine ganze Großstadt vor Angriffen
schützen Kampfflugzeuge Marschflugkörper
raketenartillerie das alles lässt sich
unter anderem mit diesem System mit
Irish abwehren in den nächsten Tagen
soll bereits das erste von vier Systemen
geliefert werden
das hochmoderne Flugabwehrsystem iresty
SLM ist auf dem Weg in die Ukraine es
soll dem Terror der Russen aus der Luft
auf die Zivilbevölkerung und sensible
Infrastruktur ein Ende bereiten
das Verteidigungssystem RST gilt das
eines der modernsten der Welt die
Raketen des Systems können
Kampfflugzeuge Hubschrauber
Marschflugkörper
raketenartillerie und bombenabwehren und
so den Luftraum sichern es ist extrem
mobil und schnell Aufbau und einsetzbar
Kosten eine Einheit 140 Millionen Euro
insgesamt sollen vier Einheiten an die
Ukraine geliefert werden eine in den
kommenden Tagen drei weitere im nächsten
Jahr
hergestellt wird Iris t von Deal company
am Bodensee in Baden-Württemberg
nach den schweren Waffen Heimat und
Panzerhaubitze 2000 ist es ein wichtiger
Baustein im Verteidigungssystem der
Ukraine
mit dem rstlm will die Ukraine Städte
Militäranlagen und die Infrastruktur vor
dem russischen raketenterrorschützen
[Musik]